[Music]
[Applause]
we'll talk to Marcellus Wiley former
defensive and host of more to it podcast
on Dan Patrick Podcast at work he'll
join us in a moment his uh interview
this week is with a former teammate
LaDainian Tomlinson and uh here is a
clip where LT talks about
reuniting uh with his father
you reconciled your relationship with
your father talk about mending that
fence and how it all came full circle
playing ball Daddy and I back with a
great relationship and heading to the
lead man that it was it was it was one
of the greatest moments in my life
uh not understanding
much about my father now
to understand our father was older you
know he was let me do the math 40 late
40s yeah that's me so when he had me he
was late 40s so I didn't get a chance to
really know him know him until I got to
college
and I can go back
you know home and visit him and we used
to sit on that porch Marcellus me and my
pops just sit on the porch and talk and
I under that I got a chance to
understand a lot about myself
talking to him
that's uh LT and it's the latest podcast
from Marcellus Wiley more to it is the
title with Marcellus Wiley wherever you
listen to podcasts also uh
danpatrick.com Marcellus joins us on the
program again give me the move yesterday
that happened or didn't happen where you
went things that make you go hmm
oh man a lot of chips were getting
pushed into the middle a lot of teams
are going all in uh you gotta love what
you see out of these Miami Dolphins
right now in a situation where they feel
like they have what they need to get
over the hump and when you go out there
and you get a pass rusher and you get a
guy who's tremendous as they did and all
of a sudden you start to look at this
team and you start to see how complete
it looks
um I've always been a believer in tour
never understood why he didn't have
enough equity in terms of being a
potential franchise quarterback I
obviously got a little derail this year
because of the concussion and everything
that happened earlier but this team
believes in him now to the point where
now they're pushing their chips in the
middle and say let's get over this huh
okay but if I compare Miami to Buffalo
now
how does Miami compare
after adding Bradley Chubb
Buffalo's a better team uh I was
answering the question to the terms of
which team did the best to improve their
chances but look at Buffalo they're
already close if not the favorite to win
it all uh been scratching at it clawing
at it obviously KC has been a barrier
for them but Buffalo seems like the team
that's poised to do it not only because
of their issues of coming up just so
short but also the fact that they still
added talent and Josh Allen's playing at
MVP level
Packers didn't do anything
but why are we surprised that they
didn't do anything they don't do
anything during the draft for Aaron
Rodgers why would we think they were
going to do something at the trade
deadline you know I think that's the
greatness of Aaron Rodgers that makes us
always think that something else is
around the corner whether it's every
single draft you're waiting for that
receiver to get drafted and they never
do it in the first round early rounds
and then you say well it's Aaron Rodgers
he'll make up for the difference and
then even for this the trade deadline
you're thinking oh they're going to do
something oh they're doing it well Aaron
Rodgers will make up the difference
there's something about Aaron Rodgers in
that building and his command obviously
we know he's eating up a ton of that
salary cap and it's for MVPs and his
greatness has a Super Bowl champion but
sometimes I think it gets exaggerated
they're thinking a little too much about
Aaron Rodgers and him fixing all
problems yeah but I wonder what that's
like when Brian guticoontz the GM passes
Aaron Rodgers in the hallway today
well I think Brian gets out the way more
than Aaron gets out of his way I've seen
that before I remember the days where
Marty Schottenheimer and his greatness
and he was a San Diego Charger coach
14-2 but him and the general manager and
AJ Smith had such a beef that when they
saw each other in the hallway they
immediately would go back into their
offices like they could even walk down
the hallway at the same time let's just
say that that organization at that time
wasn't functional and Chase Claypool he
looks like he's great he's just not
great
and and now he goes to the Bears I
thought that might be the Packers might
look at taking chase you know making a
trade with you know for Chase Claypool
yeah I'm a big believer in Chase
Claypool but I've always been fooled by
the talent lens like I just look at an
athlete and the tangibles just jump out
at you to the point where you're like
he's big he's fast he can catch you run
good routes like that's the man uh but
he's has some issues in terms of focus
and distractions that I think Pittsburgh
said enough is enough let's get rid of
him while the talent is there still and
we can see the other teams still find
Value in them uh we're talking to
Marcellus Wiley the former NFL defensive
end and host of more to it the podcast
on The Dan Patrick Network we talk about
obj as if obj is going to come back and
he's going to change the team
he's had two surgeries on that same knee
and at that position with what he relies
on
what exactly would you expect whoever
picks up obj for the second half of the
Season what are they getting
one they're getting energy
um the thing about obj
uh he plays his best when he's in the
room his energy the osmosis of that
energy is contagious like everyone feels
it everyone believes in his higher
potential he's one of those guys because
he's made those highlight plays he
became a superstar in the NFL and you
can count those guys on two hands he
became one of the guys that everyone
looked up to in some form or fashion of
like wow he's killing it when that guy's
on your roster and he still looks like a
semblance of that you believe in it it's
just that simple until he proves you
wrong you're always going to give him
the benefit of the doubt so with obj I
still think you're going to get some
potential this is a dude last time
healthy was about to win the Super Bowl
MVP yeah but then got injured so I think
they still believe in him why is it
every surgery on an athlete is
successful
laughs
because you're listening to the doctor
he has business to run every single time
he cuts you open and then he closes you
up and you're not bleeding anymore
success that's it how many surgeries did
you have
ah I think like nine
um back abdominal wall shoulder Achilles
Foot
um
uh did I say my neat knit about six
about six tonsillitis doesn't count toss
a lot is that a lot though for an NFL
player six surgeries
um I would say it's about for a guy who
started who got some reps in there a
little below average maybe average but
the thing is I had horrible timing uh
mine came first year starter contract
year in my crime like they were like oh
Wiley's amazing
[Laughter]
yeah people I always say when you know
they're like oh it's minor surgery minor
surgery is when it's on somebody else
yes yes it's crazy because
man every time you go under this is the
toughest part about surgery it's not
your injury it's not your surgery it's
not even your rehab the toughest part is
getting back on that field and playing
with the same trust and recklessness as
you did before so that sixth gear that
Ferrari six gear that you rarely touch
when you were in the zone when you had
the glow Bruce Leroy when you're that
guy and then you get hurt you have to
climb back up that hill that mountain
physically surgery rehab but mentally is
the hardest part to plant that flag back
and say I'm back most guys don't get
back to that place somehow some way some
fear kicks in
we had a conversation last hour with
Mike Tannenbaum former GM in the NFL I
said you can start your team with
anybody let's take away all the
quarterbacks
is it obvious who you would start your
team with
non-quarters
not quarterback
um Aaron Donald just jumped in my head
and he took up most of space TJ watt
jumped in my head he took him most of
his face
um Micah Parsons
oh Michael Parson's amazing yeah
um I've seen more from those other guys
than Michael Parsons but hey Michael
Parsons as well I certainly will go
Defender and more than likely a edge
rusher I wouldn't be fooled by a
receiver because the receiver is a
dependent position you need your
quarterback I wouldn't be thinking
running back obviously not the same
impact it will be a Defender one of
those three names but probably Aaron
Donald Moore TJ watt about miles Garrett
he's a monster he's a lot to deal with
for that size still has the quickest get
off in the NFL as they time it unreal
um maybe it's the Cleveland effect like
they just don't get over the hump
something about he doesn't make the same
impact place when they count the most as
I've seen from TJ Watt and Aaron Donald
your current MVP is
I mean Josh Allen last game kind of made
me say should I keep saying he's playing
that mvp level but look he's already set
a standard right now and because Buffalo
is playing so well
um I would say all things considered
Josh Allen look look at Jalen Hurst
right now he's like dude I'm I'm perfect
like my team is perfect I know it's not
all because of me but everyone said this
team would fail or succeed based on
Jalen hurts well they're perfect I'm
blemished gotta be jalenhurst in that
conversation as well more likely to make
the playoffs the Rams or the Chargers
go charges I'll say Chargers
um they don't have the hangover effect
that the Rams are dealing with on top of
some feudal play on top of Matthew
Stafford's not completely healthy right
now so what Justin Herbert and this team
getting healthy Keenan Allen's back you
start to look get Bosa back later in the
season I say the Chargers make a late
run the best quarterback performance you
ever witnessed up close was turned in by
who
oh man Dante Culpepper early Randy Moss
uh Chris Carter I think it's Randy Moss
his rookie year when he has 17
touchdowns and I remember him prep for
that game coach was saying Randy Moss is
faster than you see on film and then we
were like yeah okay he's a rookie like
no one gave him that much credit he's
still a rook we get in the game and
we're up and we're in and we're in the
dome and they're piping in false music
and noise and like that illegal stuff
it's just loud and all sudden it's quiet
because we're up
and then we have the ball and it's like
a few seconds left to go something like
that and coach said bro I remind you
Moss is faster now we've been playing 58
minutes we know how fast He Is We all
right we're winning we're good and we
went to some prevent defense which
basically means it prevents you from
winning the game and so we're like 90
yards back even the d-line is like 20
yards back and Randy Moss did one of
those and Culpepper gets a roll on
Culpepper threw the ball to the Moon it
came back down the astronaut was Randy
Moss in the end zone and they end up
beating us that was crazy he had an
electric game that time Culpepper was
bigger than you wasn't he yeah in many
ways like physically this stature people
forget Culpepper was a dude in this
league and when it gets a roll on he had
a little phenomenon followed him at a
time he was a beast but uh he could play
the ball he could spin it man and when
he had monster Carter it was silly then
he got hurt never the same yeah that
Prime I told you man it's not the
injuries it's coming back to think you
could do the same thing you did
pre-injury most athletes I've ran into
have actually failed that test it's
crazy great to talk to you again
congrats on the podcast success it's uh
more to it with Marcellus Wiley talks to
LaDainian Tomlinson and once again the
podcast is not just about the sport it's
about the person and uh that's what I
love what you win a deep dive with
LaDainian Tomlinson thank you Marcellus
all right thank you Dad talk to you soon
Marcellus Wiley former NFL defensive end
and uh you can get that podcast at
danpatrick.com